SHARAD JONES: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're going
to be talking about web app
development.
This is really our
chance to move on
from very, very
simple websites, where
we have to manage
the firewall, we
have to also write all
of our code into HTML.
And really now start to unlock
this capability to, let's say,
tap into all the tools and
technologies we already
know and a lot of tools and
technology we don't know yet,
but it expands our capacity.
And to be more concrete,
what we've done so far
has been a static website.
Meaning that you
go to this page,
it loads up a website or
it loads up the HTML file,
and the HTML file
has text on it.
In the early days
of the internet,
that was very much how
most of the web was.
It was a place you go to just
view information, and have
it listed out there.
But we know today
that we interact
more often than not with very,
very interactive websites that
have all sorts of
back end components
that are creating new
views or new analyzes,
or providing us some
recommendations, feature sets.
We're interacting with
components on the front end.
Like think about if I go
to spotify.com right now,
I'm going to get
on there and I'm
going to see links to create
playlists, new music there.
I can play music right.
On the back end, it
has all my data stored.
Every year I get
my Spotify Wrapped.
All that stuff is enabled
by modern web technologies.
And so we want to
start to move ourselves
towards that or at least
understand how that
is done, how that is managed.
As I've said before, this is
not a web development class.
My goal today is not to or
in any of these lectures
is not to teach you all the
aspects of web development.
I would encourage you to explore
our web development sequence
that we have in the department,
and that really dives
much, much deeper into it.
What I do want to
show you is that there
is a deeper side to this.
There's justification
that you should
go take some of these classes.
But also then the cloud
is a really valuable asset
in this in that, as you
build up these skill sets,
what we're going to do today is
going to be applicable there.
Because you'll learn how to make
a really cool modern website
and web application.
But what we're going
to do today is just
talk about how can
we build on that
or deploy that into a
cloud based environment.
So we have all those features
that we've talked about
so far that are valuable to us.
But yeah, plenty of
other things we can do.
So tap into databases, so we
can pull up relevant data,
we can have a login page, we
can have Python on the back end.
That's really the thing that's
going to be helpful for us today
is we're going to show
how we can basically
build our websites in Python.
What that really gives
us the capability
for is now every skill you learn
in Python throughout your time
here and in other places,
you can now show that,
display that on a website
in a very interactive way.
This unlocks another level
to everything you show,
because now there's a
level of interactivity
you can put into this.
So let's say that you
are in your Python class,
and you're learning
how to build some new
or highlight some new skill,
some new coding technique.
Well, you can put that
right away into a website
such that now I can show my
future employers, say so.
This is going to be a really
core component of that.
Now from a website side, you
have typically two main aspects,
the front end or the back end.
Front end typically
referring to anything
that the user is seeing.
And more importantly, actually
is not just what they're seeing,
but it's what's being
processed on their side, what
the browser is doing.
That's referred to
as the client side.
So this can be handled by any
number of front end frameworks
or languages.
So we've already seen
HTML, and for the most part
we'll stick in HTML in
this course and CSS.
JavaScript gives us some more
again, interactive features.
But then you get into more
complex modern frameworks
like AngularJS, React,
and many others.
And again, every day
there's a new framework
and a new technology.
So we're not here
to list these out.
Again, like I said, that is
for the web development course.
But just know that there is
this whole aspect of front end
as well as back end development.
For what we're
doing today, we're
actually more concerned
about the back end.
That is what's on
the server side.
And again, remember the server
is going to be our EC2 instance.
So the server is what's
hosting this and managing this.
And this is the code that
we can execute locally.
So we're going to
do Flask today.
But know that there are,
again, many other back end
frameworks as well too, and
combinations of both Djangos
and other popular
Python based back end.
And significantly more features.
We'll talk about
Flask in a second.
We're going to do Flask for
the most part in this class.
But just to say that if you want
to do a more complex website,
Django enables quite
a few other things.
There's also a lot
of times, again,
being a data scientist
myself, there
are a lot of times where I just
want to demonstrate something
about my analysis,
whether that's
creating an
interactive dashboard
or trying to highlight
how a machine learning
model I've built works.
I'll sometimes build very
small, lightweight applications
that I can host on the
web so that again I
can share that with anybody.
Also sometimes it's just a
case of needing a prototype.
If I'm working on a project with
a company or the only company
I'm working at, and
they need to see
what I believe a valuable
feature could be, rather than me
wasting time building
out a whole application,
oftentimes I'll build a
prototype in a much easier
to use language just
to get it working
or easier to use framework
just to get it working
and show the capability.
And then I can always pass
that off or work on a more
fully featured implementation.
But it's really
good to have some
of these other frameworks
in your toolkit
so that you can build on that.
But to that point, so
there are quite a few
other very, very
simple, friendly,
easy to use web frameworks for
hosting data based applications,
I'd call them.
You're probably familiar with
Tableau, maybe even Power BI.
These are dedicated
towards data visualization.
So you provide a data set or
a database that has the data
sets, and then you put
together the visual experience
around that.
Streamlit is a Python
based tool that is actually
really well featured.
Maybe I'll just pull it up here
really quick for reference.
So let's see here.
I debated even having us
going through Streamlit
in this course, mostly
because it's so easy to use,
but it also doesn't
really highlight really
web development.
So that's why I avoided it.
But you can see here, this
is how simple Streamlit code
looks like.
So import the Streamlit library.
Streamlit you can have it create
sliders, and all sorts of other
features too.
So if you're just making a very
simple web application that
just has to have data
connection on the back end,
I love Streamlit.
It is a go to for
me all the time.
Now again, very limited
in what it can do as
far as a full application goes.
So that's why we're not
talking about it in this class.
But just know that that's
another tool that's
available to you as well.
So check Streamlit out.
Again, if you know Python,
this is 10 seconds effort,
and you've got a website app.
And actually, the same practice
that we're going to do today
will still apply because
again, we're not really
focusing too much
on the framework
so much as on what it enables
us from a deployment side.
A Shiny as well.
That's if you are familiar
with the R programming
language like the
letter R, Shiny
is a similar kind of
framework but written in R.
So that's another tool
is available for you
to use if you are interested.
Oops, but yeah, Flask
itself is really nice, easy
to use framework, and
actually fairly robust.
Again like I noted here,
plenty of other companies
use them, use Flask in
their web applications.
So Netflix, Reddit, AirBnB,
Lyft, and a slew of others.
It's not their
whole application.
So don't misunderstand,
Netflix is not built in Python.
But there are pieces of it
that are still leveraging
Flask as a framework.
So it's widely used
in the industry,
but even more importantly,
its core principles
hold across quite a few things.
So that's why we're
focusing on it.
And I'm making an assumption
that, you all either have
been or will be
exposed to Python
quite a bit in this program.
I've also thrown around the
word framework quite a bit,
and I realize I
should have defined
that earlier on in the video.
But a framework again,
this is just saying, hey,
I have a library of code.
The same way that if
you've used Python before,
you've used NumPy, or
as I just showed there,
Streamlit is a library that
I could import in Python.
So Python is the language.
These are libraries.
Flask itself is a library.
And we call it a
framework more because it
is creating the scaffolding
almost of what it means
to build a web application.
They have a lot of back end
code that handles all the things
that we had to manually
define before and much,
much more but within this code.
And so that's why we call it
a framework as opposed to,
it's not a language, Python
is still the language,
and it's a little bit
more than just a library.
And so that's where that
term framework comes in.
But like I said, I've used
this in a ton of cases.
I've pushed applications
live that users have used
that I've written in Flask.
So very much a usable tool,
but there are plenty others.
So keep that in mind as
we're going through this.
Let me going through
this demonstration,
but I just want
to point that out.
So yeah, like the slide
said, let's stop talking,
let's do something.
So I'll close out a
PowerPoint for a second.
Yeah.
Let's save any changes I made.
So here I am on
my console window.
I'll full screen this.
Or sorry, on my terminal window.
And then let me pull up.
I'll drag this up to the top
as well to my AWS Console.
So it's the AWS Console as
you guys all know and love.
All we're going to do
today, though, it's
actually pretty straightforward.
We are going to create
an EC2 instance.
We are going to install all the
relevant libraries to get Flask
running on our environment.
Push a very, very
simple website, nothing
more than a Hello World.
But just to show how
we can push a website
live in or via
Python on our server.
And then from there
we'll call it,
but we'll go on to next in
the future video creating
a more full featured apps.
So this again just going to be
bare bones introduction to this.
So I just wanted to
walk through these steps
so you can see how
I'm setting mine up.
I'm just calling a test server.
I'm doing Ubuntu, and
I'm going to do 22.04.
Depending on when you're
watching this video,
different versions might be
available under the free tier.
You'll typically see me
though always use the one
just below the newest one.
So 24.04 is the
current newest one.
I just stepped down to 22.04.
Just in case there is
an issue I run into,
I like to use the one
that's like slightly older
just because there tend
to be more search results.
And that's only because 24.04
is relatively new right now.
But broadly speaking,
either should be fine.
But otherwise
everything else can
be left default. If you have a
preexisting key pair that you've
used, you're welcome to do
that or create a new one.
And then the only other
thing I want to note
is we'll add HTTP
traffic as a port
to open just in case we
want to access it that way.
Otherwise launch instance.
And then we wait a second.
Another thing to
note, just like we
said or I showed before
in previous videos,
when we want to access
the website publicly,
we're going to use this IP
address or you can use this DNS.
If you click it right now,
again like you've seen before--
First off, it's going
to, I guess not.
Let me even pull it up.
But you basically
you shouldn't try.
There's nothing there.
Even if I remove that, there's
nothing at this website.
So we have to obviously create
all the details on there
or the web application on there.
So now if we come and
copy our link here,
come back over to the
terminal, paste this.
Oh, great.
Connection refused.
Let me pause real quick, and
then make sure mine is working.
So just to clarify what, what
I did there as far as a change,
I just did not switch over
to the right directory
where my key pair was.
Recording videos is always
harder than just doing it
on your own.
So I make sure I had my key pair
still in my Downloads folder,
which we would not say is
best practice, but either way,
that's where it was and why
I wasn't able to connect.
So if you just see the
change your directory
over to your Downloads folder or
wherever you have your key pair
saved.
This is my key pair,
my test one that I use.
That's how it is.
And then I'm just going to
type clear to clear this out,
So it's a little easier
to see for us here.
So with that, now
all we need to do
is get Flask set
up and installed,
get some code over there
to push our website live.
So first thing I'm
going to do is run sudo.
And actually I can increase
the size of this too,
so it's not so
small for you all.
Sudo apt update slash y.
And again, all that does is
go through and push or make
available to us any new packages
that we might want to download.
Make sure everything's up
to date and good to go.
Also the notes for this
lecture are on Canvas
there just under
the file section,
under lecture 12 web app dev.
So you can always
reference it there
if you don't want to type
any of these commands
or you need to
copy anything over.
I'm going to type it all out to
make sure I don't go too fast,
but you don't have to.
So, oh gosh, there we go.
Sudo curl, so C-U-R-L. That is
to download a file from a URL.
And the URL where we're
doing that from is
bootstrap.pypa.io/get-pip.py.
So we're downloading
the pip package manager.
So if you've ever
used Python before,
you might have already had this
preinstalled on your machine.
This is just saying,
hey, we don't have it
installed on our machine yet.
And a package manager
just manager just
makes available to
us a library that
can handle the
installation of packages
specifically from the
pip library of packages.
So it's a way to install Python
packages, maybe an easier way
to say that.
So we run the curl
to download it.
And then this command I just
run the Python 3 get pip.py,
that just installs it for us.
And now we're going
to do, one other thing
it's going to be a
little bit verbose.
This you're welcome to copy.
Export path equals, and then
I'm do this forward slash colon
backward slash home
Ubuntu slash .local bin,
sorry I'll explain this once
I'm finished typing so I
don't confuse myself.
Space into there.
It's slash dot dash bashrc.
So what this command
does is it says,
OK, let's remember this double--
make sure you can
see this over here.
Actually, I just realized now
that I'm probably in the way.
So let's move my
screen up slightly.
Let's try it this way.
There we go.
So remember this double
or this double caret
kind of greater than sign
says append to a file.
So paste it at the
end of the file.
Well, the file that we want
to append to is this bashrc.
This file is run
basically anytime
we create a new instance
of our terminal.
It contains a bunch of
configuration and setup
and organizational things
for our environment.
And then what we're
doing is we're
putting in there this line
export path equals yada, yada,
yada, yada, yada.
All this is saying
is that, hey, this
is where I want you to
look for, and install
pip certain packages.
So that's why we're
adding it here.
So anytime we install a
Python library or something
like that, that's where
we want it installed.
Then we are going to
source the bashrc file.
And what that does, it
basically just runs it.
Since we don't want to have
to close out of our terminal
and then reopen it again.
This just says, OK, we'll
rerun this file because I've
made some changes to it.
But now we're good.
Our environment doesn't
look any different, aside
from having to get
pip file in there.
But what we want
to do now is make
a directory for where
we're going to build
our personal site here.
I'll call it personal
website for now.
And then we'll go
cd personal website.
And now we're in this
newly created one.
And what we want
to do is we want
to create a virtual environment
for where we do all this work.
A virtual environment
is kind of like,
it's actually somewhat similar
to our virtual machines,
except it's almost
a smaller entity.
Really, what it
is, is we're trying
to create an isolated
environment for where we do all
our Python development.
This is best practice or a good
practice, at least I'll say,
because that means then
that anything I install,
any packages I
need or any changes
I make to the
environment are isolated
to this virtual environment.
That way I can have multiple
different projects going on,
that maybe use all sorts of
different versions or maybe
the same library, but a
different version of it.
And it won't cause any problems.
So we want to create
a virtual environment.
To do that, we just
need to install
some software that allows us to
create the virtual environment.
And the first thing I want to do
is check what version of Python
I have because that will let me
know which version to install.
So if you do Python 3 and
then hyphen hyphen version.
That will print out what
version of Python you're on.
And then what you want to
run is sudo apt install.
And then I'm doing Python
3.10 because -3.10,
that's the major version.
Oops, 3.10 hyphen venv.
And then hit Enter.
And then I'll say, yes.
And that's going to install
the virtual environment
software that we need.
So give that two seconds.
You can just hit go
down or just hit Enter
on that when it pops
up on that screen.
Leave it with default settings.
And then you can do
Python 3 Python m,
and then I'm just
going to call, I'm
using the virtual
environment library,
and I'm going to call
it my environment.
And then wait a second.
And now if I do ls you'll see
this my environment library was
created in my
personal or directory
it was created in my
personal website directory.
And then I can activate
my virtual environment
by doing dot space
my environment slash
bin slash activate.
And you could have named
it again, anything.
I just called mine
my environment.
And now you'll see that
it shows in parentheses
before your commands here.
Always it's going
to show this myenv.
That's how I know that
I'm in my environment.
And then I can run
deactivate, and that
will deactivate my environment.
But this again just
isolates all my libraries
in there, which we'll see
becomes really, really useful
as we go to deploy the website.
So now we can run
pip install Flask.
Remember, pip is
the package manager.
So pip install Flask.
And now we're all set up to
basically build our website.
So all we need to do is create
a minimal website to make sure
that works.
So I'll just do nano
and app.py right here
in my personal
website directory.
And then I'll just start
typing some Python code.
Again, this is not
a Python class.
So by no means I do I expect you
to know all of what we're doing,
but I'll explain it in
case it does matter to you.
And also for anything
we do in this class,
you're welcome to just
copy and paste my code.
I'm not going to have you guys
write any sort of novel code
that's beyond the
scope of this course.
Then app equals Flask name.
So what this does is create
an instance of a Flask
app and one nice short line.
We could have also done,
if name equals main,
then do app.run
like the usual way
you do that if you're
familiar with writing
Python applications.
But this is a little
shortcut for that.
Then we'll do at, so this
is literally at symbol
like I'm typing shift and 2
to create that little symbol.
And then app.route
parentheses slash.
So what this says is whenever
somebody comes to my IP address,
right, my website at
the default location.
So just at the route or at
the home directory in a sense,
then this function
is going to run.
And I'm going to just
call my hello world.
But basically, whatever
you have after that route,
that's going to run
at that location.
So you'll see what that
means here in a second.
We'll do return hello world.
We'll do it as a header.
So again, to repeat that,
when I go to my IP address,
just set the regular IP address,
it's going to run this function.
It just knows that, hey,
they came to this location,
I should run this function.
What does this function do?
Well, right now it doesn't
do anything interesting.
It just immediately returns a
text string, and specifically
an HTML text string, because
the default assumption
or the default rendering of
these pages will be HTML.
We'll do HTML only
in this class.
But again, just know that that
is why it's returning that.
As we'll see in the next
video or in future videos,
we can add all sorts of things.
And we can have very, very
complex file structures
where we have separate
HTML templates that allow
us to pass information to them.
But for right now,
we're just going
to have it return raw
HTML exactly like this.
So I now I'm going
to click Control X
so I can exit out of this.
And then Y to say, yes,
I'm going to save this.
And then enter that I'm
fine with this name.
So we see that we have the
file there that app.py.
It has all of our code in it.
If I just cat app.py, I can
see all the code we just wrote.
And now we're almost
ready to launch it
or the launch the application.
Now one thing we
do want to change,
is we need to actually allow
users to come into our page.
So we showed how before
with the previous website
when we accessed via HTTP
that we accessed at port 80.
So this is exactly
the same idea.
So if I come back
to this instance
here, and go to Security.
So this is just me going back
to my EC2 instance on this page.
And then go to Security.
You'll see my inbound rules,
my outbound rules again.
So again, inbound rules
right here, that's port 22.
That's for SSH
access because that's
how we're connecting to it.
Port 80 is for our HTTP access.
And then the default port
for Flask applications.
When we launch the flask app,
it's going to put it into port
5,000.
That's just what they chose as
the default location for it.
Meaning that if I
want to access that,
I need to go to my IP
address colon 5000.
If I do that without
changing the security rules,
we can actually
try it right now.
If I launch this website,
we shall keep this,
it doesn't want to do this.
Let's copy this
here, paste this here
and do colon 5000 It's
just going to hang there.
Nothing's going to happen, and
it's going to throw me an error.
So what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to come over
here, go to Security.
Security groups.
So I'm going to click
on my security group.
I'm going to edit inbound rules.
Go to Add Rule.
You can leave it as custom TCP.
Then I'm going to add
5000 here for this one.
And then just to be
pedantic, we'll do 5000,
and I'm going to click this
one just to colon slash 0.
So I'm just adding
these two rules.
Then I'm going to click
save rule or save rules.
And now we have or we are
allowing traffic in through port
5000 from anywhere.
So conceivably-- Oh, actually I
should launch the website first,
then that should work.
So to launch the website, we're
just going to come over here.
I'm going to do export
Flask app equals app.py.
And this just allows
me to type just
Flask run any time I want to
launch the site without having
to specify what application
because I'm just
running this specific site.
So now I'll do Flask run hyphen
hyphen host equals 0.0.0.0
And, ops, so we
go a bad request.
Weird, what a bad request.
Check here really quick.
I make sure I didn't
miss a step on here.
So we're doing, let's
run host 0.0.0.0.
Sorry I'll pause here and
I'll come back to that one.
Once again, I should
never be a live performer
because it's very simple fixes.
But either way, the only
thing I had to change.
So if I come over here, you'll
notice that I have HTTPS.
I just need to remove that HTTPS
and turn it back to an HTTP
because like we said, we're
not doing a secure website
right now.
So just changing that to 5000.
So again, to clarify, if
you run into the same issue,
I clicked open address or
I copied this one here,
and then I pasted that and
the default assumption here.
Or better say that if
I go colon 5000 here,
and I ensure that it's not
HTTPS at the beginning,
then it should work just fine.
But either way, you
can see now we've
got a publicly hosted website.
Again, if you were to go
to an Incognito Window,
you'd be able to hit this
in the exact same way.
So you only just copy and paste.
Again, this is not logged
into anything on my account.
So this is as if you're
coming from any other computer
in the world.
Notice on the back end here too,
we can see successful requests.
All these are when
I reload the page.
So if I hit run
here again, it'll
put another entry,
another log entry in here
if we're running the page
or launching the page live.
So it's all to
say now that we've
got a way to build
a web application,
and launch a page again.
Nothing different
fundamentally from what
we did before in the
sense of we still just
have a very bare bones
hello world page.
I mean, you can paste
the same HTML code
you had from before into here.
The real power to me is
that now all of a sudden
we have this live web page.
Also to close out of that, I
just click Control C. Notice
here, Control C exited
out of this kind of a--
or stop the app from running.
If you reload the
page now, it won't
load because it's not running.
But either way,
the real power is
that now we have all
of this in Python code.
So you can now imagine we can
do basically anything in Python,
and push it to the site.
Opens a whole world of
opportunities for us.
So we'll call it there for now.
I had enough errors for one day.
And in the next
video, we'll elaborate
a lot more on how we can build
all sorts of other features.
Last thing I'll
note is just again,
we want to terminate everything
that we don't need anymore.
So since I'm done with
this, I'm going to exit.
Then I'm going to come back
over to my Console here.
Come over on Instances.
Note the test server
was the one I was using.
Instance state,
terminate, and terminate.
So that was 30
minutes, not even,
probably 15-20 ish minutes
of having the instance live.
So we're still talking
probably around $0.01 of cost
if you're not on the free tier.
So hopefully it's not
costing you too much
to work through this, but
just make a note of that.
Either way, thank you for that.
Thank you for bearing with me.
When you inevitably
run into issues,
now I hope you feel
better to reach out to me.
Let me know if I can help
you out and debug this.
So I appreciate,
and have a good one.